The guy texts you really late at night.
Why would he do that?
'Cause maybe he likes you?
I think maybe he is sleeping.
And he's a sleepyhead?
Cool!
Do you guys know what ghosting is?
Like, if you have one boy and if you're scaring him,...
...it's like you're both scaring each other.
If I like a boy, should I take a selfie and send it to him?
And then he might text you back.
If he doesn't text me back, should I text him and say,...
"You're being totally rude."
You could just say, "You used to talk to me."
"You're ghosting me."
And then he would know.
You guys are best friends, right?
Yeah.
Okay. Well, I'll let you have a moment.
Do you think it's okay for girls to ask guys on dates?
Of course it is.
The guys say they should go out on a date, so both of it's okay.
So, yes, it is okay.